Fernando wrote in what would happen if
we extended human lifespans to 500 years
or even a thousand well we spoke to
Aubree DeGray about this earlier in the
week and there's a lot of frantic
hyperbole about what would happen if we
extended human lifespans and then
there's also more more sort of calm
voices I think Aubrey de Grey would be
one I still believe the risk aversion
that we talked about with Aubrey de Grey
is an issue but not as big of an issue
as it's sometimes made out to be because
you know as an example if you're 30
versus 70 driving in a car has a certain
amount of risk right you're more likely
to die driving in a car than you are
getting on a commercial plane I don't
know people whose willingness to get in
a car based on the probability of being
in a car accident is different when
they're 30 or when they're 70 now you
could say well David that's because even
though it's way more likely that you
would die in a car accident than on a
plane it's still on any given car ride
very unlikely statistically that you
would get killed so it's not a very good
example but I think when you apply it to
most areas of life I don't observe
people being drastically different in
terms of their risk aversion when
they're 20 30 40 50 60 unless
significant changes have taken place to
their life circumstances so maybe a 500
year lifespan would sort of become the
norm and it wouldn't affect risk
aversion that's interesting because I
remember George HW Bush will skydive
monumentous birthdays like I think he
did it at 80 85 90 even maybe and would
he be willing to do that if he was
expected to live another 400 years
maybe so but maybe not I mean
skydiving's not too incredibly risky or
anything but I actually don't know how
that is
yeah it seems dangerous but you don't
really hear too often about people dying
doing it although maybe you don't hear
about it often because it's so dangerous
that it's sort of expected like yet
people are going to die doing it it's
not that weird the one thing I do think
would require sort of reframing for
people would be careers and finances if
one could live 500 years instead of
maybe having you know for the average
person working for a significant period
of time in two maybe three field
during their life maybe it would be much
more common that you go through eight or
ten very different fields you go back to
college when you're a hundred and you go
back again when you're 200 and you you
sort of start over and go into a
drastically different field and that
relates to economics as well because
when you think now about the power of
compound interest and how much savings
early which will translate to in dollars
available at retirement if you're
talking about a couple hundred years in
a few accrued cumulative interest every
ten bucks you spend now has a much
greater impact later in life yeah you
would not be able to retire at the age
of 62 anymore that's for sure I was
thinking about that one too because you
know I have no interest in becoming say
a lawyer or a doctor okay what have you
I don't think anyone wants me performing
surgeries on them I think that's fair to
say not as an unlicensed doctor anyway
no no but if I was to live another few
hundred years I think I would definitely
go back to school and become much more
well-rounded have all these different
careers under my belt I think so I think
so of course in 200 years it would cost
three hundred fifty thousand dollars a
year to go to Pat's alma mater of
Suffolk University and that would
probably a financial consideration as
well yes I think those are some of the
major shifts that would take place if
human life lifespans were drastically
extended and also I think willingness to
go through certain medical procedures
would change right because if you have a
procedure that you evaluated age 60
based on how many years you're likely to
live and how intense the recovery would
be and how much benefit you would get
from it your calculation might be
different if you expect to live 90 years
versus you adversity if you expect to
live 200 years and you're sort of what
medical procedures you might tolerate
we're talking about like something like
an e transposed or replacement anything
like a heart transplant either I'm a ban
in that whatever I think I think it
would just for all medical
considerations it would be a factor life
expectancy being so drastically
different would be a factor in terms of
thinking about what procedures do you
want which procedures are worth it
financially which in the u.s. is a
consideration